[Music]
everyone good morning thanks for being
here I'm Chris and I'm a p.m. at fabric
and now firebase and I'm also a
co-founder I was the co-founder of a
mobile startup so I know firsthand from
experience if I'm talking to customers
like you just how hard it is to get more
users building a really good growth
funnel is insanely hard and it's always
changing it's super complex and so as a
p.m. over the last couple years I've
been focused on this problem of growth
for mobile apps and especially focus on
the identity portion of growth and a lot
of people don't think the identity is
like a really important part of growth
and growth hacking and whatever but it
actually really is because you can have
an amazing onboarding funnel but if
people can't or won't log into your app
then you don't get a user you don't have
growth and so it's super important and
we've especially seen a lot of great
success with using phone numbers as a
effective identity for growth so why
phone numbers one they have a lot of
great benefits one their global every
single person in the world who has a
smartphone has a phone number that they
had memorized and actually in a lot of
emerging markets we've learned that
people prefer to use our phone numbers
as our identity instead of an email
address or another form of
identification and second phone numbers
are higher quality they give you higher
quality users because they're more
expensive the mass produce they're
naturally resistant to the kinds of
abuse and fraud you might see more often
than other types of identification and
also I think most importantly for this
discussion is they enable really low
friction sign-in for apps and websites
and again like I said sign-in is such an
important part of your growth funnel
over 90% of people who have issues
logging into an app are going to leave
and so I think it's a scary number but I
think it's a great opportunity that if
you really focus on identity as part of
growth you can have really awesome
benefits and so if identity is so
important to growth then why is logging
so hard to use and I think as
developers as web developers we created
the login screens and so like why are we
making these screens so hard to use and
over the years I've noticed like they're
smelly too big I think two big areas of
why login friction is so our login is so
high friction one big one isn't a
problem of optimization we're trying to
do so much in a little screen that
should be simple as said instead in
addition to just trying to log somebody
in or sign them up we're also trying to
get a way to contact them by getting
their email address we're also trying to
enforce some level of security usually
with some sort of password credential
criteria and we know it's developers
that passwords still increase security
as much as they increase frustration and
friction one big reason another big
reason why log in is so high friction is
on the opposite side of the spectrum and
that and I'm definitely guilty of this
myself is we're so focused on the core
value of the app that we're creating
that we don't really spend a lot of time
on login it's just like something that
we throw together before we ship but the
big disconnect there is that the first
screen our customers see is a login
screen often and so the last screen you
thought about it's the first screen your
customers are going to be experiencing
so huge disconnect and those are two big
reasons why there's a lot of friction
and login and it's developers we know
that login is harder than it needs to be
most developers are not happy with their
sign-in experience but I know like it's
rational that we'd rather focus on the
core value of our apps our core ideas so
we want to get out to the world and
dealing with login as hard there's UX
implications there security implications
and it's just not something people using
our app is more important to us than
people logging into it at least when
we're building apps and so with all that
in mind a couple years ago our team
wanted to experiment taking phone
numbers and wrapping them into a really
simple login experience and it looked
like this instead of entering your email
address and phone number you to our
email address and password you get to
your phone number and in return you get
a six digit code you punch that code in
and you're logged in really simple
secure login with no password we took
that experience and dropped it into a
really simple to use SDK called digits
digits was something that people from
any technical background could dump into
their apps or websites and a few more
moments and it takes to actually log
into digits and will let it go and I
went was I think pretty well since
launching almost 150 million people have
logged in with digits all around the
world that's been a really fun ride then
we've learned a lot but I think what
I've really enjoyed the most is talking
to developers like you and hearing your
stories about the things that you care
about when it comes to growth and
identity identity in an authentication
and obviously performance is a huge
factor that our good friends at goblet
replaced email login with Phone as one
of the options for the wrap and they saw
a 45 percent increase in sign-in rates
imagine your own growth funnel and
making one small change that can give
you 45 percent more users every day into
your app I think that's cool for a
couple of reasons one it shows that
phone is a legitimate way to log people
in and second it shows that fact like I
said like any changes you can make to
the identity portion of your growth
funnel might have huge impacts for your
entire growth all the way through or
musically who is improving the quality
of their accounts by enforcing digits
phone verification so what they're doing
is they're reducing fraud on their an
app economy which I think it's a really
smart use of digits again at Russ
periscope they're early partners two
digits and are still using us and by
letting us handle their onboarding flow
for them they're able to focus on their
core value which is delivering live
video to people anywhere in the world or
dubsmash who again they relied on us to
handle almost two million people per
month through dubsmash so that they can
focus on the core value of what they
offer to customers and so these kind of
topics have come up over and over again
trust performance and reliability and
performance has always been the biggest
thing because frankly you hired us to do
a job the job is to give you more users
and we wanted to give you more users and
so earlier this year when we joined
Google we saw this really amazing
opportunity to take all the iteration
and UX research that we put into digits
kit and combine it with a really unique
capabilities that Google has to offer
and so we put our heads down and a
couple of days ago you saw some really
cool announcements and I think that what
we came up with are some really awesome
next evolutions and so not performance
together and firebase and so to share
how you can take advantage that today
we're gonna be talking about two topics
one for those of you who are already
managing your own SMS backends you know
how hard it can be to actually get a
well formatted phone number from a
customer and so it's been really cool
new API so we're going to be discussing
first in second I'm really excited to be
sharing firebase more details on
firebase phone authentication which has
been a really tight collaboration
between the digits engineering team and
firebase to create a brand new service
that I think is philosophically and
effectively the next logical evolution
of what we want to do it digits in terms
of phone off performance it's a really
amazing system and all cells are really
easy to use migration path for digis
customers and so I would encourage I
mean to discover to take a look at it I
think it's really badass and so the get
it picked off
please welcome because on stage who's
going to be talking about phone selector
and SMS retriever yeah
and hello everyone my name is Vikas and
I work in the Android or team at Google
I'm going to talk about how we enable
you to support phone numbers for
authentication if you have an existing
back-end infrastructure that you are
already using for verifying the phone
numbers such as for sending SMSs to your
users you may have your own SMS
infrastructure or you might be using a
third-party service such as Twilio so as
Chris mentioned using phone numbers for
authentication is great as it offers
several benefits over traditional
authentication methods but still signing
in a user with phone numbers is still
problematic for Cu some users and for
app developers let's see what a sign-in
experience with phone numbers looks like
today it involves two steps first
getting the phone number of the device
and second verifying the phone number
most apps perform verification by
sending an SMS to the users device with
a one-time verification code that the
application then verifies so the app has
to get the phone number of the device
and then read the verification code from
the SMS so how do the apps get these two
things most of the apps employ basically
ask the users to enter these values but
that's not a great solution for many
reasons first manually inputting the
phone number is painful it adds a lot of
friction for the users to provide phone
numbers to your app it's also
error-prone it's important to note that
every failed verification because of a
typo in the phone number adds costs to
the app developers because they end up
sending an SMS to the wrong phone number
let's say the user provides you the
phone number and you send the SMS to the
phone the next step for you is to get
the verification code from the SMS again
asking the user to provide you the
verification code is painful for the
users it requires the users to leave
your app go to the SMS app copy or copy
or remember the verification code from
there
come back to your app and then provide
it there it's a lot of work for the
users many users find it confusing and
it's not a great experience so many app
developers have recognized these
problems with the manual input and what
they've started to do is they are now
reading the verification code and the
phone number automatically but this
approach has its own problems let's see
getting the verification the phone
number from the device and the
verification code from the SMS
automatically requires your apps to get
permissions from the users and this
looks something like this these
permissions allow the apps to get the
access to all the phone calls and all
the SMS messages of the user users are
left confused as to why your app needs
access to all these phone calls and SMS
messages so this this leads to a low a
low adoption rate and a poor user
experience and from privacy perspective
it's not a great solution for your apps
with Google Play services SDK we are
offering you best of both the world we
enable you to read the phone number and
the verification code from the SMS
automatically without requiring these
extra permissions for reading the phone
number we have the full selector API and
for verifying the phone number we have
the SMS retriever API
since this API is a part of the Google
Play services SDK
they are also compatible with the older
versions of Android platform let's take
a look at the phone selector API first
the phone selector API provides the
phone number to your app with a much
better user experience and no extra
permissions using this API you can
launch our dialog which shows the phone
numbers on the device to the user when
the user selects the phone number that
they want to use to sign-in into your
app that phone number is provided to
your app immediately without requiring
any extra permissions you can check out
the usage of this KPI in
in the apps like mineral lift and
Flipkart let's see how you can use this
API in your app first you create a hint
request object and set the phone number
identified supported field to true and
then you get a pending intent from that
hint request for the phone number select
the dialog once the user selects the
phone number that phone number is
returned to your app in the
onactivityresult it's that simple once
you have the phone number the next step
for you is to get the verification code
to verify the phone number in order to
help you with that we have the SMS
Retriever API so let's take a look at
that SMS Retriever API provides you the
message content to your app without
requiring any extra permission and the
key part is that it provides you only
the message targeted to your app all you
have to do is you have in your SMS
message in addition to the verification
code you have to include an app specific
hash this app specific hash is a static
hash that you can just include in the
SMS template without requiring many code
changes let's see how you can use SMS
Retriever API in your app when you want
to verify the user's phone number on the
device you start the SMS retriever this
makes it wait for one matching SMS which
includes the app specific hash after
starting the SMS Retriever you can just
send the SMS with the verification code
and the app specific hash to the phone
using any back-end infrastructure of
yours once the SMS with the app specific
hash is received on the device it is
provided to your app via a broadcast in
your broadcast receiver you can get the
message content from the extras once you
have the message content you can extract
the verification code and verify the
code just like you would normally do
this the vet or the SMS retriever API
you can use it
for not just signing in the users but
also for reuse cases such as for
payments the SMS retriever API will be
available in Google Play services it
will be available in the Google Play
services in the coming weeks but our
early partners who have tried this API
have loved it here are some testimonials
from some of our partners many of our
partners like of--they they love the
fact that it works with the diva tears
work with their existing infrastructure
we have carefully designed our API so
that they are very easy to integrate
with your existing flows Myntra for
example was able to successfully
integrate the SMS retriever API in their
existing sign-in flows in just three
days with one engineer here are other
testimonials many of our apps have been
able to get rid of the scary permissions
and streamlines of phone number
verification flows because of our API
gasca's chat actually found out that
their conversion rates increased after
they integrated their flows with our API
is so I just talked about how with phone
selector API and SMS retriever API we
enable you to simplify the phone auth
process if you already haven't back-end
infrastructure in place next we are
going to talk about the firebase phone
logs which helps you get started with
the phone and if you are looking for an
end-to-end solution this is how it will
help you so with that please welcome
depth we're going to talk more about the
firebase for not thank you
thank you for cause and hello everybody
my name is Debra she and I'm the product
manager for firebase authentication you
heard about some really cool things that
phone number authentication can do for
your application and today I'm really
excited to talk to you about how
firebase phone off can make it possible
to build all of these really great flows
end-to-end and very easily so before we
start I feel like I have to acknowledge
that as soon up since we've launched
phone number authentication has been one
of our top feature requests constantly
to all the developers that tweeted post
it on Stack Overflow or follow the
feature requests I just want to say that
we've heard you I'm really excited to be
able to bring this functionality to
firebase now and it's no surprise but so
many people have been asking for this
today's apps need to be able to support
high quality low friction users from all
over the world and engage with them in
new ways and that makes phone number off
really valuable
but the truth is for a lot of the apps
that actually don't have phone number
authentication today building it in the
first place can be a real struggle Chris
talked about a lot of the pains that
users go through it's also really
painful for a lot of developers first
thing you'll need to do is integrate
with an SMS provider and get coverage
with carriers to send SMS and then
you're going to want to expand your
offering globally to support all the
different areas that your users might
come from making sure you perfectly
localized along the way after all of
that you need to build secure
authentication that means generating a
one-time code verifying it from a user
minting cryptographically signed tokens
persisting sessions writing your
anti-abuse logic I don't know about you
but that's not exactly what I was
looking forward to when I started to
write an app that's why I'm really
excited to tell you that this week
firebase launched its phone
authentication 80 is the first thing
that we allow is we enable basic sign-in
and
not flow don't lower what Chris talked
about earlier with digits on all of the
platforms that we supply iOS Android and
web and on Android we actually allow for
a few and built-in enhancements vikas
told you a little bit about the SMS
retriever api which actually increases
overall conversions from users so they
don't have to end up going to the SMS
app and parsing it and I'm excited to
announce that this is going to come
built into our Android API so finally we
have a really new cool piece of
functionality called instant
verification on Android I can't wait to
tell you a bit more about that the iOS
and web api are actually available for
you to start trying today and the
android api is becoming in a few weeks
but in the meantime let's go ahead and
see what these with these API eyes are
capable of first things that this we
want to make sure we enable your app to
do is allow you to sign in and sign up
your users so for example if you're in
an iPhone the flow might look a lot like
this perhaps you're one of the many
modern apps that integrate email
authentication as well as different
identity providers and in this case you
decide to go ahead and sign in with
phone number all a user would need to do
is enter their phone number and you can
go ahead and pass it over to us will
validate the phone number handle any
normalization logic that needs to happen
see if this is a new user or returning
one and we'll go ahead and generate a
one-time code associated with this
request from there we'll handle sending
this one-time code through an SMS to
your end user so you don't have to worry
about any of those pieces your user will
simply pass back the code into your
application and which you would just
pass right back onto us and we will
verify it will handle any of the complex
logic and deduplication if you sent
multiple SMS by mistake or any of the
other edge cases that might arise and
the user will go ahead and enter their
code will validate it and we'll go ahead
and mint cryptographically signed tokens
persist sessions the whole
authentication nine yards
and you won't have to worry about how
any of it because all you'll have to
worry about is how to best and warmly
welcome your users into your application
so that's kind of what the actual api's
look like for signing in and signing up
users on all the platforms that we
support iOS Android and web but I'm
really excited to talk about some of the
enhancements that we're able to make on
Android
the first one is Auto retrieval sure is
very similarly to what the cost
discussed earlier and comes built in if
you use our phone off API for auto
retrieval the user goes ahead and click
sign-in a phone number this time they
can actually select their phone number
if you integrate with hint selector
it'll be Auto populated into the
application will validate it once more
Wilson will generate the code but this
time when we actually send the code in
the SMS will be able to pick it up from
the background will auto retrieve it
directly parse it out and populate it
into the application and the best part
of all of this is your user never
actually had to leave your application
go to an SMS tab wait for it and then
copy and paste the code into your UI
they stayed in your application the
entire time and it was a really seamless
experience for them overall that's all
that you ever have to do the last piece
is our infrastructure that I'm really
excited to talk to you about today is a
new feature on Android that we're
calling instant verification instant
verification works exactly like it
sounds like it allows us to verify the
phone number without sending an SMS into
the user
it appears instantly let's take a quick
look at how it works
this case user might see the screen
again where they get to select the phone
number directly that's we read off their
device this time when they enter their
phone number and you call our api's
we're going to do first check that check
we'll go ahead and see if we have
verified this phone number on the device
recently if we have we can actually
instantly verify the phone number the
next time around without needing to send
any additional SMS we think that this
means there's no wait time no SMS or
anything else just peers
simplicity I'm really excited about the
potential this has to significantly
improve user experience and greatly
simplify the lives of our developers I
think one of my favorite things about
firebase phone off is that all this
powerful functionality is also really
easy to use there's essentially just two
steps to go ahead and get started the
first thing you need to do is just
enable phone off within your project in
the firebase console this is quite
literally clicking on the phone selector
and enabling phone off with a simple
flag clip it doesn't actually get much
easier than that the second thing you
need to do is just integrate with our
SDKs and our API s in order to be able
to use this functionality
now our headless api's don't enforce any
UI so to give you programmatic access to
under to our underlying infrastructure
that you can use in any way that you
choose and it's really easy to use on
Android in order to get all the Crofts
awesome functionalities that I talked
about the actual ability to generate and
send codes the auto retrieval even
instant verification comes down to just
one single API call and the
implementation of the callback that you
care about so in this case all you would
do is call verify phone number with a
phone number that you pass in and
implement a few callbacks for example on
verification completed where you can
decide whatever it is you'd like to do
once we've either auto retrieve the SMS
instantly verify the phone number or
whenever the user is just decided to be
signed in I think all of this
functionality is really powerful
these api's are very simple to use and
give you programmatic access to some of
our most incredible infrastructure here
at Google but I think it's really worth
asking what about UI building
authentication UI can be pretty complex
you need to handle all sorts of edge
cases across all the different platforms
your application might support and even
after you do all of that you want to
make sure that your login UI is
actually high-performance and I will
give you good conversion rates it's
Chris talked about earlier this isn't
really what a lot of you want to spend
your time doing the last the first
screen that your users see is often the
last screen that you think about and
building out all this you I can honestly
be painful trust us we know because
we've actually done it we wrote out all
the code for the different phone
authentication flows that we've talked
about just for the UI components on
Android iOS and web and just to write
the phone authentication flows across a
few of three platforms it can be several
thousands of lines of code now if you
decide to be now if you decide to go the
way of a lot of modern applications and
integrate different identity providers
such as Google Facebook email etc then
this is just going to get more complex
and if you actually end up wanting to
integrate all these different sign-in
providers into your application well
doing identity and user signup it's
probably going to become your full-time
job that's why I'm really excited to
announce that firebase phone off is now
also part of firebase UI and firebase UI
is an open source repository on github
that we maintain that gives you the best
practices and sign in and sign up that
Google has studied over our long history
of doing identity work directly and out
of the box for your applications this is
really bringing years and years of
knowledge from Google's I understanding
of how to maximize conversion rates
directly into your application it's
really simple to integrate into your app
and it gives you the best practice flows
for all the different platforms
best of all firebase UI is completely
open-source and fully customizable so as
soon as you integrated into your
application you can go ahead and tweak
and tailor it directly into the needs of
your app however you decide you would
like to but you don't just have to take
my word for it on how easy firebase UI
is to use and how easy these API start
to integrate I can actually show you so
I call this part of my talk what could
possibly go wrong because it is not only
a live demo deadline
to do in order to show you the cool
functionality and how easy it is to
build into our application but before
this week I'd actually never touched a
line of Android code before in my life
luckily building phone authentication is
actually really easy and I'm going to be
able to do it I hope in just a couple of
minutes into my application so before
this demo the only thing I've done is
actually create a project and as you can
tell there's not a lot going on here not
sure I could actually do that much more
all I've done so far is just get the
dependencies as you know the public
versions of the Android API will be
coming out in a few weeks from here I
can actually build so an authentication
into my application in just three simple
steps the first step is I'm going to
link firebase to my application do super
easy to use Android studio plug-in I'll
go ahead and go to authentication click
email password and as it ends you can
see I've set up my dependencies and I'll
just hit connect to firebase this is a
going to open up a dialog that allow me
to either create a new firebase project
or link to an existing one this case I'm
just going to link to easy-off which is
the firebase project that I'd set up now
that I've connected it to it I'm going
to set that with step one connecting
this to the CLR through the Android
studio plug-in was all I needed to do
for step one and step two is even easier
I'm just going to go over to the
firebase console go to the
authentication tab go to sign-in methods
and here we can see all the different
sign and methods that firebase
authentication currently supports I've
already configured a few in the past
like email Google and Facebook I'm just
going to enable phone this part is quite
literally just that flag flip I showed
you earlier and we're done with step two
now if you'll believe me step three is
just as easy as the last two even though
it's a step where we write code all I'm
going to do is go to the open-source
firebase UI github repository scroll
through the readme ignore most of it and
go to this one section that I care about
where I'll be able to copy and paste the
code directly into my application to get
my phone off
you I built now this allows me to
support a lot of different sign
providers like the ones you saw before
and in this demo instead of Twitter I'm
going to decide the support phone
verification that was it that's all I
had to do luckily because again I don't
actually I'm not actually an Android
developer once I go by this application
if I could switch to my phone please
thank you I will be able to show you
exactly all the different floats that we
integrate with n2n so now I have
multiple different login methods enabled
on my demo app very easily I can show
you exactly how the phone off clothes
work in real life fingers crossed to
have carrier coverage here first thing
you'll notice is firebase UI integrates
a pin selector directly so I didn't
write any additional code for this but
it's able to pick up my phone number
from the device and I can just simply
enter it directly into the app now when
I hit verify phone number it'll go ahead
and send me a code which will directly
get read off the SMS and I don't know if
you actually caught it because it was so
fast but the number was thank you very
much the code was sent to my device
immediately written from the sim but
from an end-user perspective it was the
easiest thing I've done all day all I
did was really tap my phone number and
everything else was taken for me the SMS
was delivered it was parsed it was taken
I never left the app now let's imagine
that I'm coming back to the application
maybe after a week or two and I'd find
out this time I'm going to try and them
a really cool piece of functionality
that I'd mentioned earlier instant
verification this time around when I go
to the application hit sign on phone
number again it'll pull up the phone
number from my device just like last
time and I hope what's going to happen
is I'm just going to do simple single
tap login where I go ahead and select my
phone number it sees that I'd already
been verified in the past and that was
it no SMS was sent nothing else can we
see an instant replay maybe because that
was so quick there is nothing no SMS
sent there was no need for a user to
wait for anything but instead we were
able to just validate that we'd verified
it and log them in to right
into the application so I'm really
excited about this functionality the
potential it has for where we can go in
the future and I can't wait to see how
you integrate into your applications we
go back to the slides thank you thank
you so I think one of the things you
just saw is how easy it was to build
firebase : authentication from scratch
and I think one other thing that we've
thought about a lot as we've actually
developed this is how do we make sure we
have the best possible experience for
digits developers as chris mentioned
earlier building firebase tone
authentication was a really close
collaboration between the firebase off
and the digital team and we want to make
sure that we were able to warmly welcome
digits into the firebase family so I'm
happy to announce that we serve to roll
out migration pathways for digits
developers will they'll be able to link
their fabric accounts with firebase
projects and we'll handle the user
importation and all other tasks required
in order for them to get set up for
their first time from there they can go
ahead and use some migration guides that
will be published soon in order to
integrate the new firebase SDKs into
their application and that's all they
should have to do there won't be any
additional friction for your users who
won't have to necessarily real authentic
a back into your application and I hope
all of you stay tuned on the fabric site
for the coming details I'm really
excited that we've launched phone
authentication because I think now
firebase is an even more comprehensive
authentication solution now we support
all the different major sign methods
your application might want to support
like email authentication phone numbers
and some of the top identity providers
like Facebook Google Twitter and github
we also give you easy user management UI
from the console as well as SDKs in
order to do all the different tasks that
you might want to in behalf you can
bring your own custom authentication
solution to firebase if you already had
one and I think best of all we give you
drop-in and fully customizable
open-source UI that reflects Google's
best practices so you never have to
worry about how to best can write the
conversion flow through your application
you never have to worry about all the
thousands of lines of code that it might
take
I think one of the things that's great
about firebase authentication is that
most of the services are completely free
to use and I'm really excited to say
that was phone off we've spent a lot of
time thinking about how do we come up
with the most friendly pricing structure
for developers as possible we have a
really generous free tier where I think
for up to ten thousand verifications per
month we're actually going to be able to
give all the verifications under this
threshold for free this will cover the
vast majority of applications and I
think it's more than 90% of its odds
developers will be able to use the
service completely for free if you do
grow wildly successful we want to make
sure that our service continues to grow
sustainably and scalable with you and we
also want to make sure that we give you
really simple and easy to understand
pricing so we're only going to charge
you based on what you care about which
is actual verification of the user and
we're going to make the pricing
structure really simple just one cent
for verification in US Canada in India
and six cents in the rest of the world
for any of the verifications that go
above and beyond the 10,000
verifications
a month I can't wait to see what you all
build when this is in your hand
so to recap kind of on what we've talked
today we've really talked about two sets
of optimizations I think Google is
enabling for all the different
applications out there that care about
phone numbers if you have your own phone
off infrastructure already there's phone
hint selector and SMS Auto retrieval in
order to really optimize those flows and
make your end-user experiences much
better if you want to build a phone
authentication solution from scratch
firebase phone authentication will give
you the entire process and to end with
some of our built-in enhancements very
easily and I think is a really
compelling way to start getting into
this space and being able to integrate
this powerful technology into your
applications like I said before the iOS
and web API is for fire be to an auth
are out now and the Android API is
everything will be coming out in the
coming weeks but in the meantime I do
hope that you'll go ahead and check out
our documentation try us out today and
if you have any questions whatsoever
all of our contact information is listed
out on the screen and we'll be hanging
out outside these temps and in the
firebase band box for a little bit
afterwards as well I really cannot wait
to see what you build with this new
technology and really excited to help
and continue to support our developers
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]